From the Library of Congress and the Smithsonian National Museum of African American History and Culture.
A second person, Andy Snell.
Okay.
Today is Friday, the 22nd of July, 2011.
My name is Joe Manier of the Southern oral history program at the University of North Carolina at Chapel Hill.
I'm with our project videographer, John Bishop, and we're in Beacon, New York and delighted to be with Mr. Pete Seeger this morning to do an interview for the
Civil Rights History Project, which is a joint undertaking of the Smithsonian National Museum of African American History and Culture and the Library of Congress.
John's going to make a quick adjustment.
He's moving a little laundry on the clothesline, and I think the change of the backdrop is a little...
Okay, we're still worldwide.
Mr. Seeger, great to be here and to visit with you.
Well, thank you for coming all the way up here.
Yeah, it's a pleasure. Nice to be here. It's a beautiful day. We got this beautiful view and it's lovely.
I thought I might ask since we're here in Beacon and place you've been for all these years, I thought I might ask you to recall if you could
have the Paul Robeson concert back in September of 1949 in peak skill, where I think you opened with a few songs and it was quite a day as I understand.
I realized only a year or two ago that that attack on the Robeson concert, they were actually two of them, August 27th and September 4th.
You may have saved America from a full-fledged fascism, whatever J. Edgar Hoover could put into effect.
He had concentration camps already up for about 12,000 people, but he had been unable to persuade Congress and Truman to pass the necessary law to let him fill them.
I was probably one of the people he was going to put there.
In July of 1949, Truman sent one of his high officials. I think it was the Secretary of State up to peak skill and spoke to the American Legion.
He said, this man Robeson loves Russia. He hates America. He's coming here to sing.
I'm sure you know what to do, and he went back to Washington. In other words, he gave him the green light to do whatever they wanted.
50 years later, I learned more about what happened then because the Robeson Foundation had a press conference in on September 4th, 1999.
People came for telling what they knew of the event 50 years before.
A man in his 60s said, I was a teenager then, and I was talking with some friends on the sidewalk.
When a truck pulls up and a policeman gets out, he says, you all get in the truck. We're going down to Arseneen Beach and collect stones to throw at the commas.
So it was not a great big secret.
Now, I'm told that the police force, as well as the American Legion, were infiltrated by extreme right people.
There was a Klucluck's clan chapter just a few miles south of here, and there were others down nearer to peak skill.
There were also some German Americans from Lake Valhalla, who had never really gone along with the war against Hitler.
Right after the attack, bumper stickers went up.
There were signs about 20 inches wide saying, wake up America and under peak skill did.
And in Europe, they said, that's the same sign that went up after Crystal Nocht.
Wake up Germany Munich did, or wherever Crystal Nocht started.
And they'd all been printed in advance, and they went up right away.
Interestingly enough, they all disappeared just as quickly as they went up, about five weeks later.
And no one has been able to find exactly where the order came, but it was obviously an order from somewhere high up.
And now, I think they found out that it had backfired on them.
People all over the country saw those hate-filled faces.
And on TV, you could hear them, shout, go back to Russia, kite, nigger lovers, wham.
And there was an ugly scene, and they found now Truman needed to sell J.A. Duhuver.
No, that kind of thing doesn't go in America.
Let me take you to a place that had a very different spirit about it.
I think in 57, 58 you would make various visits to Islander.
What do you and I visited there because Alan Lomax told us about the place?
And when we went west to visit his family, out in Oklahoma and Texas, we stopped him to say hello.
And the photograph that was taken of me playing the banjo, and listening to Woody playing the guitar, that was taken there in 1940.
And in 1957, it was the 25th anniversary of the founding of Highlander,
Boer-Zilphia, Miles Horton's wife, Zilphia Horton.
And I guess you know it's spelled Z-I-P-H-I-A.
She was killed by drinking some poison cleaning fluid, I think.
And I got a phone call, I think, from Miles Heng-Pee.
Can you come down here?
It's the 25th anniversary of Highlander, we can't have an anniversary without music.
And without Zilphia here, would you come down, sing a few songs?
So I went there and King and Abernathy and Rosa drove up from Montgomery,
and King gave us a short speech.
And afterwards, we all were photographed in front of the barn,
along with a curious Horton Miles teenage daughter.
And that photograph has been well used.
That's the first of time I ever met King.
Only other time I met him was a year before he was assassinated.
I was asked to sing a few songs at a big peace rally outside the United Nations.
I just had been 80,000 people there.
And I think it was the only day after that he had spoken at Riverside Church.
And he probably said essentially, the same things, maybe a little shorter.
I saw a black car inching its way through the huge crowd and heard people whispering,
he's here, he's here.
And the black car got about 20 feet from the speaker stand.
It took six men to hold the crowd away so they could open the door
and push their way towards, took about five minutes to go that 20 feet.
And I wondered how can a person live with this kind of adulation?
And that's where I heard him say, I have to face the fact that my country
is the greatest pervert of violence in the world.
I must get out of the ad-man.
I'm sure that LBJ just lost his temper then.
He said, after all I did for that guy, now look what he does to me.
He just got boiling mad and finally he slams his fist down and picks up the phone.
Whoever do what you want.
Are those thoughts for a past?
Sure, John's gonna have us pause for a moment.
With my reading one morning in the New York Times,
a tiny little two-inch piece on the back pages saying that there was a bus boycott
in Montgomery, Alabama.
And I somehow got in touch with the reporter and said, can you give me the address of the people behind the boycott?
And he gave me the address of the Montgomery Improvement Association.
And I called up and got ED Nixon on the phone.
He was the person that Rosa called when she was arrested and she was allowed to make one phone call.
And he said, Rosa, I'll be right down to pick you up, but he said, this is what we need.
That teenager that tried to stand up to the police was pregnant.
And we couldn't have gotten the community behind her.
Everybody knows Rosa.
And don't know the details.
But he also knew that King was a fantastic speaker.
And he called up, I found this out later.
And he called up King and said, could we hold a protest meeting at your church?
And King says, well, I'm new here, brother Nixon.
And let me check with my deacons to make sure they approve.
Call me back in two hours.
And two hours later, Nixon called up.
I'm glad to say, brother Nixon, that the deacons approve.
You may have the meeting at our church tonight.
And Nixon says, Reverend King, I'm so glad you said that because I've just told 200 people we are meeting at eight o'clock.
Oh, it's a good thing the deacons said, yes.
And that's when he made that most important statement, probably several times.
We will win this buscot boycott if we are nonviolent.
And I'm sure he had to reiterate this in the future weeks.
There might be some doctors or lawyers, African-Americans, who's business was going to be hurt.
And Dr. King, we can make a few compromises.
But if we, this will lead to trouble.
And we don't want to see violence.
And he said, what are you doing tonight?
Can we discuss this?
And because he'd already gotten phone calls from angry young people said, look, they've tried to kill us.
And they've beaten us.
Why do we do something to them?
And he would say, are you free tonight?
We have to talk this over.
And he'd put these two groups of African-Americans facing each other and say, we have to solve this problem.
And he didn't need to do too much talking.
But they had to each state the position and listen to the other.
And finally came to a compromise.
They would continue, but they would try and find ways.
There'd be no violence.
And then, of course, this man should be given more credit in the civil rights movement.
Bull Connor.
I knew his name in 1940.
I was hitchhiking through the South.
And people said, you're going through Birmingham.
Stay out of the way of Bull Connor.
He's the police chief.
And I was staying with a man who'd been beaten up very badly, Joe Gulder.
And he also knew, stay out of the way of Bull Connor.
He lived about 12 miles north.
Seven miles north.
I think he's 12 miles north, and I stayed with him.
And his teenage daughter, Marjorie.
She later on married her man, named Franz, Marjorie Franz.
And I think she only recently died.
Wonderful person.
But Bull Connor had lots to do with.
Well, he was in effect the mayor because he had his own people.
And Marjorie finally told him what to do.
And it was he using violence that really opened the eyes of the country of how terrible that whole system down there was.
We have neighbors here.
And we didn't realize things like this could happen in America.
When they saw the Hoses pointed at the people rolling around on the ground,
and they were trying to keep the Hose from hitting their face.
And the dogs biting the children.
And that was Bull Connor's work.
I wanted to ask about another element of your visit to Highlander in 1957 when you met Reverend King.
Reverend Abernathy and Rose Parks for the first time was I think that may have been the occasion that they first heard you play.
We shall overcome.
I didn't know how to play it right.
But I did sing it.
Zilvia had taught me the song when she was north in 1946, I believe, almost 10 years earlier.
And I printed it in our little song magazine, People's Songs.
I didn't print it right.
What really made the song spread was Guy Caravan and Frank Hamilton learning to put it in a special kind of rhythm.
It's called 12-8-time.
You know when you have four beats per measure.
And if you want to make the notes fast, you usually double them.
You get a 1, 2, 3, 4, 1, 2, 3, and 4.
But 12-8-time means that you triple each one of those beats.
One to T, one to T, one to T, one to T, one to T, one to T, one to T.
And I had known the time.
I used it when I sing Jacob's Ladder.
We are climbing.
Jacob's Ladder.
So it was not unknown to me.
But Frank Hamilton and Guy Caravan, Guy Caravan, I hope you get the spelling right.
Way back in 1960, before that, had been learning gospel songs at local Baptist church.
And we got into these subtle variations in rhythm.
Rhythm is such an important part of African American music as cities, of course, in African music.
A song isn't a song unless you know it and get the rhythm right.
You might have the melody exactly right, but if you don't have the rhythm right, you don't have the song right.
But I think I remember where you have written that Anne Braden was there as well as she was driving Dr. King after that 57 meeting.
That's right.
She drove him north and going through Tennessee.
I see your members sitting in the back seat.
We shall overcome. That song really sticks with you, doesn't it?
I didn't sing it a great deal, but I sang it more.
And then in 1960, Guy Caravan was the full time man in charge of music at Highlander.
And he decided to have a weekend called Singing in the Movement.
And there were people, mostly young people, from Maine, pardon me, from Texas, to Florida, to Virginia.
They came from all over. But there must have been about 50 or 60 people there.
They raised the money for the fair somehow.
And we sang from Friday evening all through Saturday and ended finally going home on Sunday.
And we shall overcome was the hit of the weekend with that new rhythm.
It was about five weeks later when the organization was started in Raleigh, North Carolina for young people.
Now you tell me the exact name.
Snake.
Student, nonviolent, coordinating committee.
And somebody shouted from the crowd, Guy, teach us all we shall overcome.
And he did.
And that's when they adopted the idea of cross your hands.
And your right hand grasps the left hand of the person to your left.
And your left hand grasps the right hand of the person to your right.
And you're closer together, your shoulders touch.
You sway slowly from right to left.
And this also is a great African tradition.
And you move your body when you sing.
You don't just sing no matter how a glorious voice you have, you sing.
And you get harmony.
And it was three years later I was able to give a concert in Carnegie Hall
before taking my family overseas.
We visited 35 countries around the world across the Pacific, Australia, then up to Indonesia, then to Japan, where Toshi's father accompanied us.
And saw his own family that he had not visited for 50 years.
And his older sister kneeled down with her head touching the concrete and would not rise until he said, please rise sister.
He was the oldest male in the family.
And many of his brothers and sisters had died.
And of course his parents were a died.
But anyway, that carnival concert I got a number of my neighbors here in Beacon.
Black and white.
To come down.
I guess I must have paid their fair.
And I had in the afternoon a rehearsal with him said, some sat on my left, some sat on my right.
Nobody sat in the back all they'd see was my rear end.
And I said, if you get the answer back in the harmony, you know answer back is such an important part of African American music.
Whether it's pop songs or jazz or gospel songs.
One voice answering another.
And so if I said if you get the answer back right and there'll be mics on you as well as on me, then I think we'll get this audience singing.
And the Columbia Record Company shelt out the cash.
You know, it's not a nice story to tell.
But you know if you want to record at Carnegie, you have to pay $100,000 to the stage crew.
They're union members and this is the union rules.
$100,000 if you want it.
So Columbia had Rick and John Hammond Jr.
He was quite an extraordinary man.
I didn't find out until recently he was the great grandson of Cornelius Vanderbilt.
His mother was a granddaughter of it.
But she'd gotten religion and hardly looked at her son so he was raised by servants.
And as a teenager would go down south and listen to street singers and so on.
And he had the music where he found Brownie McGee and Sonny Terry.
And he had them sing at the concert he put on to raise money for all things, the new masses, the Communist magazine.
In 1938, I was up in Cambridge, Massachusetts, that's in my last few weeks at Harvard.
The concert was called From Spirituals to Swing.
I think Count Basie's orchestra was there, but I may be wrong.
It might have been another swing band.
And he had a variety of extraordinary musicians.
So he put up the money for the...
So my Hammond put up the money?
Columbia.
Well, that Spirituals to Swing, I think John Hammond raised that separately.
That was for the new massacres.
And my concert was in 1963 and I was briefly a Columbia recording artist.
Was that your appearance at Carnegie were the freedom singers with you on that occasion?
I'm not sure.
My memory isn't good, but they might have been with me because it was in 60, I believe,
that Bernice was expelled from the local college in Albany, Georgia.
And...
Now, wait a minute, wait a minute.
You were in Albany in 62.
Yeah.
And I didn't do a very good job.
Why do you say it into the job?
I said, you should know that all kinds of people have different kinds of songs.
And I said, for example, white people came over here with old ballads from England.
And I sang them some English ballads.
And somebody leaned over to Cordell Regan, who was later married, Bernice.
He said, if this is white folks music, I have to say I don't think much of it.
So you didn't get quite the crowd response that you thought you might down there
and addressing all these civil rights, SNCC folks down in Albany.
But you out of that came your relationship with Bernice Johnson?
That's exactly right.
She and Cordell and that tall man who now lives in Kentucky, a good songwriter.
And another man that I can't remember their names.
I'd gone to the office of in Atlanta and said, you know,
just like the Fisk Jubilee singers, that singers, these singers could raise a lot of money for you traveling around.
And that's when they started the Freedom Singers.
And in 63, Toshin I was getting ready to go overseas.
I think we left in late July, went to Hawaii first.
Or maybe we went to the West Coast, sang in California, and then Hawaii.
And then went on across the Pacific, stopped at Samoa, two Samoas.
And then Dora Australia and so on.
And sang for our supper, as I said, over 30 countries.
But Toshin had the names and addresses of all the colleges I'd been singing to.
So it's matter just a couple days' work to send out letters or recordings maybe.
And the Freedom Singers to large numbers could have been over 100, see.
And gave them the address or the telephone number of Bernice.
So Toshin set up their first tour.
And that's why you were two later, Bernice named her daughter Toshy.
Toshy is the best organizer in the family.
I'm, uh, get lots of ideas, but I'm not a good organizer.
When you came back from that long overseas tour, by summer of 64, you were in Mississippi.
I guess so.
I've forgotten where exactly.
Places like Hattiesburg and, and, uh, Meridian.
I met Bill Kunstler in the Arab, Arab plane.
And we landed at Jackson, Mississippi.
I remember when I was singing a couple of things I saw the body of the man in the seat in front of me, stiffen.
As though he was probably outraged at some of the things I was saying.
And sure enough, he was waiting for us in the anti-rum outside the airport.
There's a little place where people take off their overcoats or whatever.
And I mean, he said, you come down here to sing for the niggers.
I said, I hope I can sing for everybody who wants to hear me.
He said, well, well, you better watch your step.
If we weren't here, I'd knock the shit out of you.
But there was a look magazine reporter with me.
And I didn't guess he didn't know exactly where he's from.
So I was saved that time.
And I might have been in danger, but I did what I was told.
I went down two or three times, as I remember.
I was singing to about 200 people in a church when they gave me a piece of paper.
So they found the bodies of Goodman, Schwerner, and Cheney.
And I made this announcement.
There was no shouting.
There was no anger.
So lips moving in prayer.
And I think I sang the song that Fred Hellman made up, oh, healing river, send down your waters.
Send down your waters upon this land.
And Fred Macoff wrote the words up in Long Island, and Fred put the melody of it.
It's a beautiful song.
Any other things stand out when you think back to Mississippi in that freedom summer?
I don't know whether that summer of when, but after the killings in Selma,
when they tried to have a march to Montgomery, they ended up getting permission, formal permission.
And they said there would be helicopters overhead to make sure it was safe.
And Toshin, I were invited.
In fact, I have kept a copy of the telegram from King.
The federal government and the courts have spoken.
And we will march from Selma to Montgomery on such and such a date.
And we answered back, said, we're coming.
We actually didn't start from the center of Selma.
I think it was a mile or so outside of town.
And we joined about 300 people, I'd say, maybe more.
And it was raining half the time.
King and other people were up in the front.
We were about halfway down.
I remember Harry Belafonte standing by the side at one and urging us on.
Oh, you'd find out that the new way of singing, we shall overcome.
That was the first time I heard it that way.
Not everybody liked We shall overcome.
The great playwright, what's her name now?
She wrote Broadway hits.
She says, someday, someday, that's been said too long.
Lily and Helman.
And probably there were others who felt this way at any rate.
We'd sing We shall overcome right after it, somebody would shout, what do we want?
And the whole crowd would shout at the top of their lungs.
Freedom! When do we want it?
Now!
And that took away the softness of, someday, someday, someday.
And I remember the helicopters overhead flying over the cornfields on either side.
So to watch for somebody with a rifle.
Let's take a little break for a minute.
Just like that on the river.
I have a song 50, say, on Newberg Bay waiting for the wind and tide.
They couldn't get past stormking until the tide changed or the wind.
But with both the wind and tide against them, they're making a pretty good time.
She was pretty.
I don't know when you just know if that's clear water.
Sure, yeah, that is the clear water.
It's sleeping in the river.
Don McLean wrote, by Miss America Pie, at a local clear water fundraiser.
Is that an arrow? Is that an arrow? Is that an arrow?
Look at Chevy, is it the living?
Yeah.
You had mentioned earlier the vivid recollection of the big rally at the UN
where Reverend King had given the address just the day after Riverside.
And, um, Lack Doctor King, you really thought about these issues of social justice in a fashion
that brought these concerns together as one common broad arena of effort,
nonviolence, anti-war, environment, social justice, racial equality.
I'm interested in your thoughts about, and women.
And women, certainly. Yeah.
I'm interested in your thoughts about the late 60s in the United States and thinking of the shift towards the way SNCC came a part a little bit.
The movement took a different direction.
Dr. King began to lift his voice on economic and foreign policy issues.
Yes.
King undoubtedly knew that he'd be assassinated by some local person or somebody high up.
And that's why he gave that final speech.
He knew he didn't have long, and, uh, and saying now, in effect, he was saying,
you have to pick up the torch.
Nobody knows if there'll be a human race here in a hundred years.
Kurt Vonnegut, uh, was so pessimistic, he didn't think there would be a human race here.
I tell people, I think we have a 50-50 chance.
I think if we are still here, it will be large numbers, whether it's hundreds of thousands or millions,
I don't know, of small things that do it.
A few people sitting in an office somewhere, more likely, a few people,
uh, doing something together locally.
For example, a woman here in this town of Beacon,
had a tried in several ways, bringing black and white together.
And she, her husband was dead, and she was retired,
but she got together with some other women and said, there should be a one day a year
when the mainstream could be closed and we'll have been called the Spirit of Beacon Day.
They invited the charge ten dollars for any organization they wanted to get about 12 feet along the sidewalk,
to put up a table, and they could sell food, or they could play a record, or have a piece of paper.
They called up first, I think, 24 churches, white and black, and Latino,
and conservative and radical.
And so they were on, and then they had the middle class organizations
that Kewanaus, the Lions, the American Legion,
and they also invited our little Beacon Clearwater Club, this Beacon Slope Club.
And, uh, at 12 o'clock, the police set up barriers,
and if you wanted to go east to west or west to east, you had to leave Main Street and go down one of the side streets.
And the first time it was done, they had a few hundred people there, and next year it was twice as many.
And next year it was twice as many now, I think now about two-thirds of the town is there, like 10,000 people are there.
And there's dancing going on, and different kinds of music.
And I think I'll be down there with my friends, helping the kids group.
They're now 11-year-olds, they started when they were nine-year-olds.
Maybe they're 12 now, they call themselves the River Town Kids.
And they're not only singing some of the songs, I taught them, but they're making up new songs.
And they're singing some old songs.
And by one, I think by 12-30, they have a parade in the beginning.
It was just the fire engine and the ambulance.
But next year is the fire engine, the ambulance, and some people.
Now the parade is an hour long, and everybody wants to be in the parade.
And after the parade, then is when they improvise.
In fact, some women from a Hindu temple, now beautifully colored saris, they're dancing on a platform with a tape recording of music from India.
And 200 people watching in the minute applauding to think that this was a narrow-minded little factory town until I guess World War II.
It started with a Dutch girl.
I don't know why this isn't Dutch or something. Well, in a way, it's...
The same thing that produced the Civil Rights Movement, people of different backgrounds getting together, like Violeta Liu's whole was Italian American, mother of five, I'm told, and she came down from Detroit.
And wrist getting assassinated and didn't get assassinated.
Here in Beacon, nobody got assassinated, but I know what sparked it off.
Yes, it was sparked off because there was a high school race riot.
There was a high school race riot, and these women decided, let's get people in, they started with the churches, and the respectable groups.
Now literally anybody can... Yet the town is a town of 14,000, but 10,000 of them, right there.
Of course, some are grumbling, oh, this town's going to hell, but the kids are saying, yeah, it's fun, dad, you oughta come down.
Let me ask a final question for me, John may have questions as well.
I'm just interested in what you think these days about our situation. Here we have our first black president, and yet we're embroiled in complicated and long-running war, and I'm just curious about your perspective thinking about this long arc of history.
Well, we know that it would be compromises. I didn't think he would make so many.
However, I'm not a great politician, and it might be that those are the kind of compromises that have to be made.
On the other hand, I think if I had my brains about me, the one time I did see Obama and his wife when I sang that, when I led the crowd in singing this land as your land, I say,
don't try, I would have said, don't try and get reelected in 2012. Do the best job you possibly can, and you will get reelected in 2016, because there'll be such a contrast between what you do and what they do in 2012.
As it is, he may very possibly won't get reelected, which is a sea. He didn't make enough compromises, and that won't be the lesson.
Yes, I could have done that. I did speak to him all of ten seconds. He said to me, Mr. Seeger, my mother played me a records at age four.
I said, don't try and get elected in 2012, and you will get reelected in 2016.
This is a reaction.
I should have said that. I should have said that, but I didn't.
There are a lot of times you should have said something, and it comes out after the moment.
Well, you've said so much through your music, and otherwise, and it has sort of picked up and carried our history along. It's a real honor and a privilege to be with you. Thank you.
Well, thank you, and I'm glad to hear that you're going to help this nation remember that extraordinary man.
He had only 13 years to do what he could do. Of course, Lincoln only had five years.
Thank you.
Oh, let me tell you another story about what you'd be interested. Maybe this could help you.
I always thought that Ruthiford B. Hayes was the worst president we ever had, because he allowed the troops to go back north,
and after the Civil War, and didn't try to push through the changes with troops down there.
Incidentally, the song Michael Rowe the Boulder Shore was in a book called Slave Song, written by an officer,
a Northern officer who was stationed in Georgia, Southeast Georgia.
But there had been a lot of scandals in Grant's second administration. Grant was fairly honest, I believe,
but the people he was told to appoint were not. And there was one scandal after another after another after another after another in his second term.
And the Republicans felt sure they wouldn't not get reelected unless they found somebody squeaky clean.
They found it in the Governor of Ohio, Ruthiford B. Hayes, who had had an absolutely impeccable history in Ohio.
And they said when they were running, it was a dead tie in the Electoral College.
And then the election was thrown into the House, and again it was a dead tie.
And Republicans found one Democrat who would vote for Hayes if he would withdraw federal troops from the South.
And it's possible that Hayes might have said, well, I could resign right now, but then they'd do it anyway.
And he was a lawyer. He felt this kind of job should be done by talking anyway, not by guns.
He knew the Governor of Louisiana, and they both agreed if they had schools or ex-slaves.
Sooner or later they'd all be voting again. But the Ku Klux Klan was too strong.
And so he was out of office. However, he liked to make speeches.
And he'd jump into one of these, had this new invention called a rail road, and he gave a speech somewhere.
Eight years after he was out of office, the Supreme Court made a very important decision.
They said there's no capital punishment for corporations.
Up until that time, the state could hand give out a charter.
And if they didn't like what the corporation was doing, they could take the charter away.
But not after 1888. And Ruthford behave made a speech somewhere.
Face it, we no longer have a government of the people, by the people, for the people.
We have a government of corporations, by corporations, for corporations.
Way back then, only radicals made that kind of a statement.
Farmers trying to get better deal for farmers or unions trying to get a better deal from the job.
Yeah, indeed. I'm thinking of the invention farmers.
You did early work with music and puppet theater around farm strikes here in the valley.
Half a mile from where we're sitting was a radical summer camp for put together mainly by Jewish garment workers.
And it was called Camp Nitt Gidiget, meaning no worry in Yiddish.
Way back in the 20s.
But in the 30s, they decided to make some compromise that they call it Camp Beacon.
And I and three others had put together a little puppet troupe.
And we had some funny things.
And we also had a skit where Governor Dewey has cut the education budget.
And now without sufficient education, Pinocchio gets in trouble.
And we also had a skit we'd written about farmers not getting paid enough.
And through enough in August, the dairy farmers union went on strike.
And we had a skit already for it.
The farmer is milking the cow and he says, I don't know what to do.
My wife has taken the children and left she says I can't afford to feed him anymore.
But they were only paying me two cents a quart from milk.
They were selling it in New York for twelve cents a quart.
Somebody's making some money.
And the cow says, well, you're very foolish.
Not together, get together with the other farmers.
If you all stick together, you will be able to demand a better price.
So the cow was the union organizer.
And I played the part of the cow up there.
They were hand puppets.
And we went from strike meeting to strike meeting.
It was exciting.
And we didn't charge money for it.
We passed the hat.
And they didn't have much money.
But they'd give us a nickel or a dime.
And some people even a quarter, which was a lot of money then.
I was probably like five dollars.
And nickel was an ice cream cone or a Hershey bar.
That's what it was back then.
Do you know how that was a wonderful thing?
Let me think.
Oh, do you know Stacey White in Mississippi?
Well, she has an annual get together to remember Fannie Lou Hamer
and the things that went on back in those days.
I've got her telephone number in there.
So before you leave.
I'm not sure when.
I don't think it's in the dead of summer.
I think it's in the spring.
But it might be in the fall.
And you've attended?
No, I've never attended.
But I've sent contributions to them.
Any thought about Miss Hanger?
Well, simply that this is the kind of heroism
which it took Madgevars to.
They knew that there were people going to try and assassinate them.
She was beaten so badly that a few years later she died of her injuries.
And of course those three who were not just killed,
but terribly beaten before they were killed.
They finally got their evidence on the man who organized the killing.
Actually, there was an FBI man there the whole time.
And he could have probably did go to J. Edgar Hoover
and said, but who said oh they're probably all communists anyway.
Well let me thank you so much for welcoming us and allowing us to visit.
It's really been a privilege to be with you.
Thank you.
And you're hot.
I'll take the.
It's just lovely.
It's been a presentation of the Library of Congress and the Smithsonian National Museum of African American History and Culture.